ne fallait pas du jour c'est patrice
carteron hier dans tpm peut on a reçu
booba mais une autre personne voulait
absolument le voir il s'agit du boxeur
patrice carton il a essayé de
s'introduire dans les locaux où on vous
explique tout ça regardez hier soir
boulogne a tremblé face à cette
rencontre au sommet alors que booba
était l'invité d'honneur de tpm paix
pour parler de la polémique qui fait
rage avec charisme et étonnamment pas ce
dernier qui a tenté de l'affronter hier
soir alors que l'émission débuté à peine
sur ses huit dans les coulisses un tout
autre combat avait lieu en effet le
boxeur patrice carteron lui aussi très
et demi avec booba s'étaient rendus
devant les locaux de l'émission à
boulogne billancourt
muni d'un mégaphone le sportif a annoncé
que si on ne le laissez pas entrer il
allait tout simplement défoncé la porte
son but n'était pas d'entrer sur le
plateau en direct mais bien de profiter
de la présence du rappeur pour régler
une bonne fois pour toutes ses comptes
avec lui après avoir forcé la porte le
sportif a été bloqué par les équipes de
sécurité de la chaîne
une séquence qui a été filmé merci
booba qui était alors dans les loges de
l'émission n'a pas croisé son ennemi par
mesure de sécurité la police a été
dépêchée sur place mais l'incident n'est
pas allé plus loin
et il ya eu une scène énorme en
coulisses c'est youssef notre âge on
sait que j'embrasse qui étaient
impliqués dans l'histoire hier et
regardez bien le pousser portes de
youssef qu'il arrive on dirait qu'ils à
l'entrée d'une témoignent les routes
comme ça et faire la peine de regarder
[Musique]
l'émission en direct via d'état du brut
et du gaz
s'il vous plaît merci moi et le privé
voilà donc oui on peut quand même saluer
et dire bravo à notre équipe est
plaisante mais quand il s'agit des
professionnels et faire retomber la
pression et d'être calme et de lui de
montrer que c'est eux qui décident qui
rentrent qu'il a fait il l'a pas croisé
booba il m'insultait c'est vrai c'est ce
que vous vivez sur les réseaux ces
groupes
non non c'est dans la vidéo ils agissent
dies irae la norme
adacore très bien merci à la barre voilà
ce qu'il y aurait les poursuites suite à
cette intrusion parce qu'il ya une porte
de casser je crois qu'elle dispute alors
je ne sais pas allez voir le
commissariat de boulogne